Stephen I know it's a little soggy in
New York this morning what's it like
inside was there a line outside there
was no line I mean right before it
opened there were maybe 10 people
outside who had signed up for
appointments at about 3am new york time
this morning Apple's trying to kick the
lines to a minimum and you can only
order online for the first few weeks
yeah I mean I think this is a critical
difference obviously people queue up to
get a new iphone 6 today if you line up
all you're gonna get to do is go in and
try out the Apple watch you can't
actually leave the store with them that
said it's available for pre-order have
any specific types of models sold out in
pre-orders even so the pre order was for
all three models and you can come in in
demo all three models the apple watch
edition though will only be available in
certain stores and apples you have to
release a list of what those stores are
so it seems like some models are sold
out is this a marketing ploy to drum up
headlines I think they certainly want to
grab headlines and they also want to
grab the attention of customers by
making people sign up for appointments
and by offering the watches on pre-order
they make sure that everybody has equal
access that you don't have these lines
outside the stores where people are
waiting and then disappointed when they
sell out and the customer can't walk
away with a watch yeah and presumably
since this is a whole new category of
device there's also a certain amount of
Education a certain amount of teaching
that you have to do with customers so
they can figure out how to actually use
it Steven now that you've been inside
now that you have seen the watch now the
two of you know Ben speaking into your
phone as if it's your watch is if it
were phone what do you think we'd be
buying to watch
I mean I'm not just sure I'm quite sold
yet but I think a lot of people will be
the thing about the Apple watch is it's
a new device like you said and it has
new use cases I think most customers are
gonna have to buy one try it out and
figure out how to work it into their own
lives it's it's not something intuitive
like the iPhone where you take it out of
the box and you instantly know what to
do with it what's distinct about the new
Apple watch versus the other
smartwatches out there particularly
versus the samsung Smart Watch um I
think it's typically apple and that they
they nailed the design of the hardware
it's a beautiful beautiful object it's
not like a traditional Swiss watch but
it is a beautiful piece of hardware and
the interactions with the software
although new still feel very Apple they
take a little learning but you do get
used to them and you do find yourself
going back for more alright interesting
looking forward to it Steve and I know
you you had mentioned that you were
interested in the seventeen thousand
dollar gold one bad news i saw online i
think it's sold out till august that one
so uh good luck but I I know you've got
some I know you've got some contacts in
the watch industry so I'm not work